اهلا
بكم اشاده واسعه النطاق بادوار امير
الكويت الشيخ صباح الاحمد الجابر الصباح
الذي توفي في الولايات المتحده عن عمر
الهز 91 عاما هناك من اشد بحرصه على
الاستقرار في بلاده ومحيطها وهناك من
تستوقفهم اكثر جهوده في مجال الخدمات
الانسانيه التي من اجلها منحته الامم
المتحده عام
2014 لقب قائد العمل الانساني كما لا تنسى
القضيه الفلسطينيه وقضايا العرب والمسلمين
بصفه عامه مساعيه للمواساه وراب الصدع هنا
وهناك وينتظر ان يؤدي ولي العهد الكويتي
الشيخ نواف الاحمد الجابر الصباح اليمين
الدستوريه الاربعاء اميرا جديدا للبلاد
خلفا للشيخ صباح الاحمد الجابر الصباح
الذي نتوقف في التقرير التالي مع ابرز
المحطات في حياته ومسيرته
المهنيه علها كانت صفه لازمه للرجل الذي
رحل عن 91 عاما هنا تكرم الامم المتحده
امير الكويت الراحل كقائد انساني تقدير
لدوره ودور بلاده التي قادها لتكون مركزا
للعمل الانساني كما تصفها الامم المتحده
في تكريمها هذا عام
2014 لم تكن تلك الا احدى بصمات الامير
الذي حكم منذ عام 2006 فيها عرفت الكويت
انفتاحا اعلاميا ورفعا لسقف الحريات
وترسيخا لمباد الديمقراطيه شهدت البلاد
تجاذبات بين الحكومه ومجلس الامه ادت الى
حل المجلس اكثر من مره امر راه الكويتيون
حاله صحيه في محيط يعاني من الاست داد
وسلطه الرجل الواحد هذا ما كانت عليه
الكويت في عهد صباح الاحمد الجابر الصباح
فكيف كان هو في عشرينيات عمره بدا عمله
السياسي فكان عضوا فاعلا في قياده البلاد
قبل وبعد الاستقلال على الانتداب
البريطاني كان دوره بارزا للغايه في
ادارته للملف الاعلامي والثقافي حينها اذ
كان اول وزير للارشاد والانباء عام 62 وهي
وزاره اشبه بوزاره الاعلام في وقتنا
الحاضر في عهده انطلقت الجريده الرسميه
للكويت وولدت مجله العربي احدى اهم
المجلات الثقافيه العربيه التي قال فيها
انها هديه الكويت للعرب لكن اهم ما قاده
الراحل هو وزاره الخارجيه الكويتيه ومنذ
عام 63 وعلى مدى اربعه عقود كان الصباح
وزيرا ل خارجيه البلاد بالاضافه الى
تكليفه بالعمل في وزارات اخرى بالتوازي في
تلك الفتره الطويله مرت البلاد بعواصف
عاتيه لعل ابرزها الغزو العراقي صيف العام
90 من القرن الماضي ذلك الحدث الذي هز
المنطقه برمتها وتغيرت بعده اشكال العلاقه
في محيط الكويت استطاع الراحل العبور بتلك
المرحله الحساسه وحشد الدعم الدولي
والعربي لاخراج الكويت من تلك الازمه غادر
الوزاره عام 2003 ليمسك بزمام رئاسه مجلس
الوزراء لثلاث سنوات بعدها قبل ان يبايعه
مجلس الامه بالاجماع اميرا للبلاد عام
2006 في 14 عاما استطاع شيخ الدبلوماسيه
العربيه كما يسميه القاده العرب ان يراب
صدع عدد من الخلافات بين الاشقاء اذ كان
قليل الغياب عن اللقاءات العربيه اينما
كانت لذلك كان دوره بارزا في حل حله
الملفات الخلافيه ومحاوله حل الازمات
العربيه العربيه ليس ابتداء بازمه مسقط
وابو ظبي اذ نجح الامير الراحل في حل
الازمه التي نشبت بين البلدين عام 2011
بعد كشف السلطنه عن شبكه تجسس اماراتيه
كانت تستهدف نظام الحكم هناك تواصلت حكمه
الصباح في راب الصدوع الخليجيه كان ذلك
جليا للغايه في محاولاته الحثيثه لحل
الازمه الخليجيه الحاليه التي اندلعت بعد
فرد حصار من دول خليجيه على دوله قطر
املنا كبير جدا واملنا كبير في اصدقائنا
في الولايات المتحده في مساعدتهم بان
الامور ترجع الى نصابها ان شاء الله كانت
هذه التصريحات في واشنطن التي ادرك الامير
اهميه دورها في اي م لحل الازمه في الخليج
فهنا تنعكس قوه العلاقات الكويتيه
الامريكيه استراتيجيه وتاريخيه لكنها سارت
على خط من التوازن برغم الدور الامريكي في
اخراج الكويت من ازمه الغزو العراقي الا
ان الكويت عارضت الولايات المتحده في
مواقف تتعلق بالقضايا العربيه وخاصه
القضيه الفلسطينيه هكذا يرحل امير
الانسانيه كما وصفه العالم وامير الحكمه
كما يصفه العرب وصاحب الحكم الرشيد كما
يصفه
الكويتيون وللوقوف يوم رحيل امير الكويت
ينضم الينا من الكويت النائب علي الدقباسي
عضو مجلس الامه الكويتي والرئيس السابق
للبرلمان العربي من رام الله عبر الانترنت
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وهنا في
الاستوديو الدكتور ماجد الانصاري استاذ
علم الاجتماع السياسي في جامعه قطر اهلا
بضيوفي الكرام وابدا بضيفي من الكويت
النائب علي الدقباسي
الويت تجربه سياسيه مختلفه عن جوارها بشكل
كبير ماذا عن اهم ما قام به هذا الرجل
الامير صباح فيما يتعلق بدعم هذه التجربه
واثره في هذه
التجربه في البدايه اود ان اعزي العالم
العربي والاسلامي
بفقدان قائد عظيم كان همه ان يدعم القضايا
العربيه والانسانيه والاسلاميه بجديه
وبافعل وليس اقوال كان مدرسه تعلمنا منها
انا اعزي الجميع واعزي سمو الامير الشيخ
نواف الاحمد والشعب الكويتي على وجه
الخصوص اما عن التجربه الكويتيه فنحن
نعتقد انها ليست تجربه بل هي نظام نظامنا
الدستوري قائم على وجود السلطات وامراء
الكويت المتعاقبين رحمه الله عليهم واموات
المسلمين اجمعين كانوا حريصين على الحكم
بالقواعد الدستوريه والشيخ صباح على وجه
الحدو التحديد كان حريص على العمل وفق
النصوص الدستوريه وعلى
ايضا ارساء قواعد العمل
الديمقراطي ضيف على ذلك بان نحن نعيش في
منطقه ملتهبه وازمات مختلفه كان دور
الاقليمي دور مشهود ودور مشهود حتى من
خصومه وكان يحمل القضيه الفلسطينيه في
قلبه وانا كنائب متخصص بالشان الخارجي
اشهد لله بانه كان يحثنا دائما على تبني
قضايا العرب والمسلمين وفي مقدمتها قضيه
العرب الاولى فلسطين والقدس الشريف
بالاضافه الى عمل الدؤوب في مؤتمر
المانحين وايضا لرب الصدع في كثير من
المواقع والمواقف اللي حضرتك كاعلام
تدركها الشيخ صباع كان شخصيه نادره كان
يقرن العمل بالفعل كان يتحمل بالرغم من
كبر سنه ومرضه ان يقوم بنفسه وشخصيا
بمتابعه ادق التفاصيل كان يشرف على مؤتمر
المانحين كان يحثنا على الدور الانساني
احنا ادركنا بان هذه ما هي اهم ميزاتها
سيد علي ما هي اهم اهم اهمها رباطه الجاش
والايمان الكامل بان ليس هناك بد من وحده
الصف وتفعيل العمل العربي المشترك اهمها
كانت الحكمه وبعد النظر اهمها كان الحرص
على ان شعوب المنطقه تنعم بالراحه
والاستقرار وان يستفيد الكل وتتحقق
المصالح المشتركه وارساء قواعد الامن
والسلم في المنطقه والعالم ميزاته كثيره
رحمه الله عليه وانا شخصيا اشتغلت معه
خلال 17 عام الماضيه كنائب وكمس برلماني
واعرف تماما اني اشهد لله شهاده حق بان
فقدنا مدرسه كبيره عزائنا الوحيد ان سياسه
بلدنا تستمر وانا اعرف بانها ان شاء الله
ستستمر في ارساء
قواعد يعني ساعود لككن فقط فيما يتعلق
بالشان الفلسطيني هذه المره الكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي ايضا يرحل الشيخ صباح في ظرف
دقيق تمر به القضيه الفلسطينيه ماذا عن
هذا الفقد عن هذا
المصاب نحن سنفتقده كثيرا يعني اولا اسمح
لي ان اتقدم ايضا بالتعزيه لدوله الكويت
لسمو الامير نواف الاحمد وللبرلمان الكويت
ولشعب الكويت بهذا الفقدان الجلل
[موسيقى]
والشيخ صباح الاحمد الجابر الصباح لم شخا
عادي انا كان لي شرف اللقاء به اكثر من
مره ع مرات
ويمكنني ان اقول ب وضوح انهد تمي كو
خارجيه ورس لوزراء وكام لبد في مواقف ته
القضيه
الفلينيه كان موقفه داما بشكل كامل ومطلق
لفلسطين وللقدس ولحق الفلسطينيين في وطنهم
ويشهد له بانه لم يتعاطى مع مشاريع
التطبيع
واخذ جعل الكويت تقف على مسافه بعيده جدا
من صفقه القارن وضد هذه الصفقه عمليا لانه
ادرك مضمونها ومعناها بالنسبه للشعب
الفلسطيني من تصفيه لحقوقه الوطنيه
والحقيقه انه يشهد له بانه لم يتاثر برائ
الماضي ولم يتاثر باخطاء ارتكبت تجاه
الكويت بالعكس يعني بقيت الكويت اكبر
وافضل الداعمين للقضيه الفلسطينيه دون اي
شائبه على الاطلاق وبالاضافه طبعا الى
دوره الانساني في دعم احتياجات الشعب
الفلسطيني اي وهو طبعا كما قلتم ايه
اختارته الامم المتحده قائدا للعمل
الانساني بجداره لانه جعل الكويت بقدراتها
وامكانياتها تقف الى جانب الشعوب التي
تحتاج الى المساعده والفئات المحرومه في
المجتمعات بما في ذلك طبعا دعمه لفلسطين
ولكن طبعا لا نستطيع ان نذكر دون ان ننسى
موقفه الوحدوي العربي
والمستقل واصراره على ان يقف ضد الخلافات
والانقسامات بالعكس جعل من الخليه من كويت
مناره للوساطه وحل الخلافات بين الاشقاء
وخاصه وهذا وهذا ما اسر ضيفي هنا في
الاستديو الدكتور ماجد الانصاري الان ماذا
عن البيت الخليجي ما الذي خصره البيت
الخليجي او بقايا البيت الخليجي طبعا بدا
اكرر ما تفضل به الاخوان نعزي انفسنا اولا
واشقائه في الكويت حقيقه نحن في قطر هنا
خصوصا نشاطر اشقائنا في الكويت الحزن
بوفاه المغفور له لعلم كل بيت قطري وكل
مسؤول قطري وكل مواطن قطري بالدور الكبير
الذي قام به سموه للوساطه في هذه الازمه
الخليجيه وادوار الوساطه المختلفه التي
قام بها عبر التاريخ التي جنبت المنطقه
ويلات ازمات متعدده حقيقه وكانت الازمه
الخليجيه هذه عنوانها الابرز هو الوساطه
الكويتيه وقدره سمو امير الكويت على ايقاف
التفكير
بغزو عسكري قدرته على راب الصدع على الاقل
داخل البيت الخليجي من خلال عقد القمه
الخليجيه الاولى بعد حصار قطر وقدرته كذلك
على القيام بهذه الدبلوماسيه المكوكيه في
فتره مرضه وتعبه ونتذكر جميعا والقطريون
جميعا والخليجيون جميعا يتذكرون يعني صور
الشيخ رحمه الله وهو في لقاءاته في الرياض
وفي ابو ظبي وفي الدوحه وما زالت الابره
مغروز في يده وهو يتلقى العلاج في في حينه
فالحقيقه مكانته بالنسبه لنا ك قطريين
مكانته للخليج هي كبيره وهنا فقط اريد ان
اعرج على ادوار الوساطه التي قام بها سمو
امير الكويت يعني ننسى حقيقه او ربما كثير
منا وانا منهم لم يعاصر تلك الفتره التي
كانت الكويت فيها هي فعلا مناره الوساطه
في العالم وليس فقط في المنطقه سمو امير
الكويت رحمه الله نفسه الشيخ صباح وفور
يعني دخوله في معترك العمل الحكومي في عام
65 عمل على جهود الوساطه في اكثر من قطر
عربي جهود الوساطه بين السعوديه ومصر في
اليمن جهود الوساطه بين عمان واليمن بين
باكستان
والبنغال قبل الانفصال كلها كانت حقيقه
هذه في الستينيات والسبعينيات القرن
الماضي وكذلك حتى جهود الوساطه على فكره
بين العراق وايران قبل لحرب كان له دور
كبير منها في هذا الموضوع في السبعينيات
بعد ايلول الاسود ادوار الوساطه بين
الفصائل الفلسطينيه
والحكومه الاردنيه خلال الازمه اللبنانيه
قام بادوار وساطه كبيره وثم نجح بعد غزو
الكويت في استكمال مسيره الكويت حقيقه
اثناء الغزو وضمان ان تكون الدوله موجوده
وان تكون الدبلوماسيه الكويتيه حاضره بقوه
وبشده في تلك المرحله الاصعب بعد احتلال
الكويت كامله وثم نجح في اعاده تفعيل دور
الدبلوماسيه بعد كان الكثير يراهن على ان
الكويت ستفقد دورها الدبلوماسي بعد الغزو
ولكن بعد الغزو عادت الكويت بدورها
الدبلوماسي القوي ونجح هو في 2012 في
اعاده العلاقات الى شكل طبيعي مع اليجي
دكتور ماجد في ظل هذا الصدع الكبير الذي
يعيشه البيت الخليجي ويفقد هذا البيت عمود
اساسي هو الشيخ صباح ماذا عن هذا البيت
انا لا شك لدي انه في حال غياب حضره صاحب
سمو امير الكويت رحمه الله عن هذه الازمه
الخليجيه كانت ستكون العواقب اكثر بكثير
والازمه ستكون اكثر عنفا ولكن وجوده حقيقه
نجح في ان يوجد حاله من الاستقرار السلبي
في هذه الازمه على الرغم من تعنت الطرف
الاخر لايجاد حل لها اليوم اليوم وفي اطار
جوله جديده من الوساطه الكويتيه خلال هذه
الفتره ورحلات مكوكيه للمسؤولين في
المنطقه نجد ان طبعا نخسر اساس وعمود خيمه
منطقه الخليج والعالم العربي اجمل لذلك
حقيقه نحن نراهن طبعا
على القياده الكويتيه القادمه انها بلا شك
ستستكمل هذا الدور الكويتي الذي لم ينقطع
منذ تاسيس الكويت في كونها هي حاضنه
الوساطه العربيه وربما هذا ماس ضيفي من
الكويت النائب علي الدقباسي ايضا ذكر قبل
قليل ضيفي هنا في الاستوديو الكتور ماجد
هذا التاريخ الطويل من تاريخ الشيخ صباح
عليه رحمه الله من الدبلوماسيه حتى عندما
عرفت الكويت ازمات حاده كا ازمه الغزو ومع
ذلك لم تخ خسر الكويت دورها كوصيه كم
متحرك في محيطها الخليجي والعربي
والاسلامي وحتى العالمي ماذا عن الكويت
المنتظره الان في ظل عهد
جديد اؤكد لك بان سياسه الدوله سياسه
الكويت ثابته وترمي دائما الى استقرار
المنطقه والى ايجاد مناخ من التعاون بين
دول الجوار وعلى وجه الخصوص في دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي وامنا ان نستكمل مسيره
الشيخ صباح ونحقق وصيته وقايته ببناء
بيتنا الخليجي وامرا طبيعيا ان تحدث
خلافات هنا او هناك لكن لا بديله عن
الحوار ولا بديله عن التفاهمات والمشاورات
للخروج في بيتنا اكثر قوه وهذا ما كانان
الشيخ صباح يورينا اياه بالصوت والصوره
اقصد كان يرينا فعلا وقولا كان يتحمل على
صحته وكبر سنه ويبلغنا كيف ان نصل الى
غاياتنا وانا اعتقد ان نحن نا مطالبين
فيما يتصل في سؤالك اؤكد لك السياسه
الدوله الكويتيه مستمره وسمو الامير الشيخ
نواف الاحمد وحكومته ورئيس وزراءه اللي
كان وزير خارجيه ومسؤول عن هذه الملفات
بشكل رسمي كوزيره للخارجيه فيما يتصل في
الازمه الخليجيه او سياسه دوله الكويت
الخارجيه هو اليوم يراس الحكومه فدور في
الكويت دائما وتعلمنا انه لا بديل من
القيام بواجباتنا تجاه الاشقاء لا بديل عن
التعاون لا بديل عن الحوار لان هذا في
مصلحه الشعوب الشيخ صباح حتى اكون منصف
للامانه والتاريخ كان حريص على ان الشعوب
تحظى بكل حقها في الحريه والرخاء
والاستقرار مع وجود الراي والراي الاخر
الخلافات تحصل هنا وهناك ولن تنتهي لكن
التحدي الاكبر ان نستمر ك بيتا موحدا قويا
قادرا على مواجهه التحديات المحيطه في
منطقتنا وايضا في العالم فيما يتصل في
القضيه الفلسطينيه انا اود ايضا ان اسجل
دور الشيخ صباح اللي كان يتابعنا نحن
كنواب لسنا مسؤولين تنفيذيين وانما
مسؤولين تشريعيين نحضر مؤتمرات في الاتحاد
البرلماني الدولي والاسيوي كان يتابع
معانا وهذه للامانه والتاريخ وكان يحثنا
على دعم قضيه العرب والمسلمين وانا اطلب
من الله ان يجعله في منزله الشهداء اطلب
من كل المسلمين في العالم انه يدعوا له
لان رجل كان حريص جدا على القيام بدوره
اذا تستعد الكويت اذا وهي تودع الامير
الشيخ صباح الاحمد الجابر الصباح لتولي
ولي عهده الشيخ نواف الاحمد الجابر الصباح
مقاليد السلطه اميرا جديدا للبلاد بعد
ادائه المرتقب لليمين الدستوريه خلال
الساعات
المقبله الشيخ نواف الاحمد الجابر الصباح
الذي نادى به مجلس الوزراء اميرا لدوله
الكويت في اجتماع استث ثنائي وفقا للماده
الرابعه من قانون توارث الاماره اصبح
الامير السادس عشر لدوله الكويت وكان اخر
قرار وقعه امير الكويت الراحل الشيخ صباح
الاحمد الجابر الصباح هو اسناد بعض سلطاته
الدستوريه لولي العهد واخيه غير الشقيق
الشيخ نواف مستبقا بذلك اجراء عمليه
جراحيه دقيقه منتصف يوليو الماضي تقلد
الامير الشيخ نواف الاحمد مناصب وزاريه
ومسؤوليات عليا في الدوله شغل منصب وزير
الداخليه في مارس من عام
1978 ثم تولى وزاره الدفاع في عام
1988 وقد عين الشيخ نواف الاحمد المولود
في عام
1937 نائبا لرئيس الحرس الوطني الكويتي في
عام
1994 ثم عاد ليتسلم حقيبه الداخليه في عام
2003 قبل ان تتم مبايعته وليا العهد من
قبل اسره الحكم في فبراير من عام
2006 ملفات كثيره تنتظر الامير الجديد
محليا واقليميا في صدارتها جهود راب الصدع
داخل البيت الخليجي والقضيه الفلسطينيه
التي في حكم المؤكد ان موقف الكويت منها
لن يتغير وهو الذي اتسم بالثبات طيله عقود
رغم تقير حكام
البلاد وهذا ايضا ما ختمنا به التقرير
اسال عنه ضيفي من رملا الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي عما ينتظره ويعول عليه
الفلسطينيون في هذه المرحله الدقيقه
بالذات من
الكويت يعني اريد ان ابدا بالقول ان قدره
الكويت على ان تلعب دورا خارجيا قويا يعود
الى متانه بنيانها الداخلي
وطبعا هذا يشهد به للشيخ صباح الاحمد
وطبعا للشيخ نواف الاحمد لانه كلاهما مثل
اكد على استمراريه النظام الدستور سي في
الكويت
وفتحوا مجال واسع لحريه الراي والتعبير
والتعدديه وهذا البنيان الديمقراطي في
الواقع
المتميز يجعل الكويت قادره على ان تكون
مؤثره خارجيا نحن في امس الحاجه الان لدور
الكويت في امس الحاجه للوقوف في وجه
التطبيع الذي يشتا المنطقه والذي يمك
والذي يمثل في الواقع تبنيا لصفقه القرن
التي هي تصفيه لحقوق الشعب الفلسطيني نحن
بحاجه الى صوت حر كصوت الكويت وكل الاحرار
العرب الاخرين للوقوف الى جانب الشعب
الفلسطيني في مواجهه هذه الصفقه وفي
مواجهه التحديات التي تمثلها حكومه اليمين
العنصريه الاسرائيليه التي اليوم اعلن
نتنياهو انها ترفض رفضا باتا الانسحاب من
الاراضي المحتله ورفض وترفض رفضا باتا
قيام دوله فلسطينيه حره ومستقله لذلك نحن
بحاجه للكويت لاسناد سياسيا اولا ولاس
اناد في اطار المحيط العربي مع ضعف هائل
في الجامعه الدول العربيه في المواقف
الاخيره التي رايناها وبحاجه ايضا لاسناد
الكويت لصمود الشعب الفلسطيني وبقائه على
ارض وطنه وهو اكثر عامل مهم وحاسم في
الصراع الدائر في المنطقه وفي حمايه حقنا
في فلسطين وحق العرب والمسلمين في القدس
وفي المقدسات في الاراضي المحتله لذلك
طبعا دور دور اي الكويت مهم ومطلوب وضروري
وحساس جدا في هذه المرحله الدقيقه خاصه ان
الكويت حافظت دوما على موقفها المستقل ولم
تنحاز لتكتلات والاستقطابات الجاريه
واستطاعت ان تلعب دورا وسيطا ليس فقط بين
الاشقاء العرب بل ايضا مع الدول المجاوره
وهذا الامر مهم جدا في اطار فهم مستقبل
هذه المنطقه دكتور ماجد دعني اثير معك
ربما شيء يتعلق
بثقافه الخليجيه لطالما كان يشار للامير
الراحل الشيخ صباح بكلمه الوالد ولمن يعرف
الثقافه الخليجيه يعرف وزن هذه الكلمه ليس
فقط على الصعيد الاجتماعي وصعيد العلاقات
ولكن ايضا حتى على المستوى السياسي عندما
نتكلم عن م واسطات او دور
السياسي ما الي تعنيه هذه الكلمه كلمه
الوالد و و فيما يتعلق بربما فهم عمليه
التاثير بين هذا المحيط الخليجي وطبعا فقط
نؤكد على نقطه وهي ان هذا لم يكن لقبا
اختص به سموه رحمه الله فكما تفضلت في
الثقافه الخليجيه كبير السن وصاحب الجاه
والتاثير في في محيطه والاحترام في محيطه
يكتسب هذا الاسم لذلك نجد مثلا هنا في قطر
نحن نقول سمو الامير الوالد في وصف اسمه
الامير السابق الشيخ حمد بن خليفه الثاني
كان نفس الامر طبعا في الدول الاخرى كذلك
حول الجيل هذا من القاده الذين فعلا قادوا
بانطلاقه المرحله ولكن ربما كانت توصيف
الاهم للشيخ صباح في في السياق الخليجي هو
الحديث عن عميد
الدبلوماسيه الخليجيه لانه فعلا كان
بالنسبه لاجيال وليس جيل واحد حقيقه من
الخليجيين كان هو الوجه الدبلوماسي
المتفرد في المنطقه الخليجيه كنا كنا لا
نسمع عن دور الخليج الخارجي الا من خلال
بوابه الشيخ صباح رحمه الله وخاصه قبل غزو
الكويت كان كانت كان يمثل هو بشخصه الاداه
الدبلوماسيه الارفع خليجيا في كل القضايا
المنطقه لذلك على نشرات الاخبار عندما لم
يكن هناك الجزيره وغيرها كان هناك فقط
قنوات وطنيه وقنوات محليه لم نكن نرى في
نشره الاخبار وجه خليجي دبلوماسي له تاثير
حقيقي في بدايه تسعينيات وقبل ذلك سوى
الشيخ صباح وهو يتحرك في القضايا
الاقليميه والدوليه لذلك كونه عميد
الدبلوماسيه وثم انتقل ليكون كذلك عميد
الحكام وخاصه بعد وفاه السلطان قابوس رحمه
الله في منطقه الخليج وله هو اخر من من
عاصر مرحله من الحكام من عاصر مرحله تاسيس
الوحده الخليجيه وتاسيس مجلس التعاون
الخليجي فهو ادواره تتعدى حقيقه الادوار
التقليديه لحاكم خليجي هي تصل الى مستوى
اذا صح التعبير يعني هو الوجه الخليجي
الابرز في سياق في السياق السياسي بشكل
عام لانه كانت له هذه الادوار التي تعدت
المنطقه وتعدت الادوار التقليديه لوزارات
الخارجيه فيها سيد علي الدقباسي مسؤوليه
وحجم كبير تركه الراحل
الشيخ صباح للامير الحالي الامير الشيخ
النواف ماذا عن اهم التحديات المطروحه
برايك حقيقه لا تخل مرحله من التحديات في
تحديات داخليه وخارجيه
اقتصاديه ولكن انا اؤكد لك بان سمو الامير
الشيخ نواف الاحمد هو يعني خيري
خلف ل الامير الراحل رحمه الله عليه وهو
من الشخصيات اللي اشتغلت معه مده 60 عام
في مناصب رسميه وهو قريب جدا من الكويتيين
ومحبوب جدا من الكويتيين وقايه في التواضع
واللطف والبشاشه وينتهج سياسه الدوله ونحن
كنواب نلتقي بشكل مستمر مع سمو نائب
الامير والامير
الحالي ان شاء الله ان الله يمده بالتوفيق
ابرز التحديات على الصعيد الخليجي هو
الازمه الخليجيه اصعب التحديات ان نستطيع
واصله طموحات الشيخ صباح في ايجاد منطقه
تنعم بالسلم والامن العالميين اعانت كثيرا
ابرز التحديات محليا هو الظروف الاقتصاديه
اللي نتجت عن انخفاض اسعار النفط وايضا
نتجت عن كورونا وما شابهها لكن اؤكد لك
بان سياسه الكويت باقيه وان حكامنا رحمه
الله على اللي توفى منهم نستذكر بالرحمه
وبالخير وايضا نستذكر زعماء دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي المؤسسين اللي وضعوا هذا
البناء اللي مسؤوليتنا نحن اليوم كابناء
واحفاد ان نحافظ عليه وان نقدم كل
التضحيات ليستمر لابنائنا كمنظومه عربيه
صامده قادره على مواجهه التحديات
الاقليميه وايضا على مواصلت دورها في دعم
العالم العمل العربي المشترك خاصه في ظل
التغيرات الاقليميه وايضا العالميه
الشديده والمصالح المشتركه ونشوء تكتلات
متعدده الشيخ نواف شخصيه يعني تتميز
باحترامها للدوله وقراراتها وانا يعني على
يقين مطلق بان سياستنا مستمره وادعو له
بالتوفيق
وبالمناسبه اعلن بان قدم مجلس الامه ان
شاء الله سيستكمل الاجراءات الدستوريه في
تنصيب الامير في مجلس الامه في جلسه دعي
له النواب قدن الساعه 11
وعزانا بان اميرنا الشيخ نواف
هو
يعني يواصل مسيره العطاء
واتمنى له التوفيق واتمنى له النجاح في
قياده المرحله المقبله اللي هي مسؤوليتنا
جميعا واود ان اشكر ضيوفك ضيفي فيك
الكريمين وكل اخواننا اللي شاطر في هذا
الحزن واكد لهم ان احنا عزائنا بان الشيخ
صباح رحمه الله عليه رجل عمل عمل انساني
كثير وقدم كثير للانسان وقدم كثير الاشقاء
المسلمين ونحن مستمرين على نفس العطاء
وانا اكد لك ان الكويت ستستمر على نفس
السياسه ان شاء الله دكتور مصطفى كيف يمكن
البناء على هذا الارث الذي تركه الشيخ
صباح من قبل فيما يتعلق بالقضيه
الفلسطينيه كما قلنا التحديات التي
تواجهنا كبيره جدا اولا يعني وساكون صريح
هنا هناك
مؤامره تنسج ضد الشعب الفلسطيني لتصفيه كل
حقوق الوطنيه وهناك هناك تسلل خطير للفكر
الصهيوني في المحيط العربي وكذلك للروايه
الاسرائيليه ونحن طبعا تجرح قلوبنا بعض
الاصوات النشاز التي تظهر هنا وهناك
وتحاول ان تخلق فرقه بين الفلسطينيين
واخوتهم العرب نحن لن نسمح لاسرائيل ولا
لاي طرف خارجي بان يجرنا الى اي خلاف مع
اي طرف عربي او مع اي شعب عربي بالاحرى
ولكن نحن نطمع في موقف حازم للدول كالكويت
في وقف هذا التسلل الفكري الاسرائيلي
ولروابط
وايضا في وضع حد
لتدهور الامور نحو التطبيع مع نظام احتلال
وفصل وتمييز عنصري يمس ليس فقط
بالفلسطينيين كعرب ومسلمين ومسيحيين يمسهم
يمس بهم كبشر يمس بكل قيم
الانسانيه امامنا تحديات كبيره وطبعا انا
اذكر
ان سمو الامير الراحل كان دائما يطلب منا
في كل لقاءاتنا معه باهميه تعزيز الوحده
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وانهاء كل اشكال
الانقسام ايضا نحن نطمح لان تواصل الكويت
دورها الايجابي في هذا المجال وفي اسناد
جهودنا التي تجري حاليا لدرء الانقسام
وتحقيق الوحده الوطنيه الفلسطينيه الكامله
كاحد اهم وسائل واسباب التصدي للاحتلال
والنقطه الاخيره ربما ذكرتها سابقا ولكن
اريد ان اشدد عليها ال اليوم بقائنا وبقاء
قضيه فلسطين يعتمد على بقاء الشعب
الفلسطيني في وطنه واليوم نحن نحاصر ليس
فقط بوباء الكورونا بل باجراءات الاحتلال
الخطيره الراميه الى تهجير الشعب
الفلسطيني من ارضه هذا انا برايي مساله
حساسه ومهمه جدا ولذلك نحن نعتقد ان
الكويت تستطيع ان تقود الدرب تقود النشاط
العربي في اطار دعم صمود وبقاء الشعب
الفلسطيني وصمود وبقاء القدس نعم كخ خليجي
ما الذي ترجوه
للكويت طبعا الكويت هي حقيقه امام
استحقاقات كثيره في الفتره القادمه
وتحديات كبيره جدا بعضها داخلي وبعضها
خارجي ابتداء من ازمه كورونا وتداعياتها
الانسانيه والاجتماعيه امتدادا الى الازمه
الاقتصاديه التي تواجدها او تواجهها دول
المنطقه اليوم ولكن ايضا هناك تحديات
خارجيه كبرى على راسها الازمه الخليجيه
وطبعا هذا
الاصطفاف الواضح في المنطقه بين معسكرات
ذات مشاريع متضاده الكويت التزمت الحياد
لفتره طويله واستطاعت ان تؤسس حاله من
الحياد الايجابي من خلال دورها في الوساطه
ومن خلال دورها في قياده المبادرات
العربيه وضمان نجاح التكتلات العربيه وال
الخليجيه وعلى راسها طبعا مجلس التعاون
الخليجي ما نرجوه الان اولا هو مزيد من
الاستقرار ومزيد من الازدهار في الكويت
طبعا
وانتقال طبيعي سلس كما هو الحال دائما
وكما تعودنا دائما في الكويت ل السلطه
وقياده جديده تستلم الرايه وتبدا يعني او
تسير على ذات المنوان الذي سارت عليه
الكويت منذ يومها الاول ولكن ايضا نتمنى
ان يكون الدور الكويتي كما كان دائما ان
يحافظ على هذا الدور الخارجي في مثل هذه
التحولات ايا كان شكلها في مثل هذه
التحولات يكون دائما هناك نوع من الانكفاء
الداخلي ما نتمناه ونرجوه ونتوقع لدوله
لها حضورها ومكانها مثل الكويت ان يستمر
هذا الدور الخارجي خاصه في اطار راب صدع
الخليجي والمبادرات العربيه الم متلفه لان
حقيقه منطقه الخليج العالم العربي والعالم
بشكل عام بحاجه لدوله نموذجيه مثل الكويت
في دورها الخارجي شكرا لك دكتور ماجد
الانصاري استاذ علم الاجتماع السياسي في
جامعه قطر وكذلك لضيف من رام الله عبر
الانترنت الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين
العام للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وكذلك
لضيف من الكويت النائب علي الدقباسي عضو
مجلس الامه الكويتي